[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a gagné on est content
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on les deux équipes on très bien jouer
au meilleur niveau possible mais à la
fin de la journée il fallait bien que
quelqu'un
gagne
[Musique]
satisfait les éléphants surtout que
c'est les champion en titre vraiment en
sort vraiment c'est c'est une
résurrection résurrection pour les
éléphants et puis vraiment le chemin
continue et la coupe gr Abidjan il faut
tomber pour mieux se relever moi c'est
toujours ce que ce qu'on m'a dit parce
que c'est dans l'échec justement qu'on
crée la victoire et finalement si on
n'échoue pas une fois on peut pas savoir
justement ce goût là ce goûtl qui a la
victoire et aujourd'hui on est heureux
justement parce qu'on a perdu 4-0 on
nous a humilié mais aujourd'hui là c'est
nous qui allons humilier les gens on va
[Musique]
terminerne l'équipe de Côte d'Ivoire
nous a vraiment fait plaisir voilà nous
av fait plaisir on avait jours de cri
jours de cri jours de cri n jamais battu
la Côte d'Ivoire donc il y avait pas
d'exception ce soir on avait confiance
au
maillot Seigneur
m'aité
alléluia
[Applaudissements]
point